Okay.
Should be live here.
Hi.
We're doing something a little different
today. We're doing something a little
different today.
Oops. This thing not work. What's the
stupid club command?
I thought it was just club. It's not.
Oh, I'm in the wrong tab. That's fine.
Uh, so here's the plan today. Um,
I will let the stream start up a little
bit before I go over the full thing, but
I have a real task that is actually part
of my work. Um, and I'm going to try to
use clog for it, but I'm going to try to
use it in a completely different way
from before in which I'm going to
actually be steering most of the code
directly. Uh, it's going to look very
very different and we're going to see if
this is useful.
One moment.
Hey, Muffin.
How am I supposed to watch and you? What
are your thoughts on the RLM paper? What
RLM paper?
Oh, the recurrent M. Dude, why do you
why do people expect that I've read this
[ __ ] Like,
why would I have read that again?
Oops.
Cool.
Maybe not.
It's fine. We'll do this.
Let's see how it goes this time. This is
going to be very different. Yeah, seems
interesting, but that's not what like I
don't do that stuff. Muffin.
I got my hands full with the RL I work
on.
So, okay. I'm trying to think when I
want to give the overview of what I'm
doing. I think once I have this thing
fully set up, hopefully that will allow
the stream to have warmed up a little
and I will talk about exactly what I'm
using this for.
This is going to look very different
from the other day. I That was I think
that was the most depressing stream I
I've ever done the other day. That was
like completely stupid.
What's the plan for this attempt? It
will be very different. Let me finish
going through the setup here and I will
say exactly what we're doing.
last attempt I will give before I say
the actual details of the project.
So last attempt it was look the idea was
hey everybody's been telling me these
models are super good and you should
just use them. let me like let you guys
tell me exactly what to you how to use
them so nobody can say I was using them
wrong or whatever. Um
well and behold the models are good but
actually the users are even stupider
than I thought. Uh I don't think I did a
single thing last stream that I couldn't
have done blackout drunk. Like I could
have done every single thing I did on
the stream provided I could stay awake.
Like I could have probably slammed a
whole bottle's worth of vodka Red Bulls
and still been able to do that. And uh
that's not good. So today we're going to
try something very different where I
actually see, okay, the models are
pretty good. Uh the usage pattern is
brain dead. Let me see if I can come up
with a better way to use this that does
not involve a full frontal lobotomy.
And I have a new project for that that
is less standalone. It's a substantially
harder project in some ways. Um, but
it's one where the pieces that are hard
are things where uh Claude should be
good and it's mostly like fiddly docks
and fiddly testing and stuff.
Okay, perfect. So, really high bar?
I think like thinking should not be a
high bar.
Why depressing? Because basically all of
my viewers were very happy to just not
think at all.
Okay, so this is the plan today. Um, I
have a little task that I need to do. It
is something that I know exactly how to
do.
uh I know exactly like the ops that
should be specified. I don't really know
the library functions to call. There are
a few other things and it's something
that would be kind of fiddly for me to
set up manually.
So what I want to do is I want to like
really have a lot of control here and
essentially use this as much more
powerful fuzzy docs than before. Uh that
is also applying those changes. So,
I'm going to retain almost as much
control as I have in my normal
programming. But the hope is that
instead of this thing saving me
thinking, this thing saves me
bullshitting. Cuz, you know, a lot of
the work that I normally do when I'm
dealing with low-level, poorly
documented stuff or just new stuff,
there's a lot of bullshitting. Um, so
hopefully I'm going to be able to use
this thing to allow me to focus on the
actual building, not like the highle
super underspecified. No, the actual
precisely specified thing that I want uh
only really using this thing to help me
get those details uh quicker.
Okay. And the project, it's a kernel
bench, it's a kernel benchmark project.
I have some benchmarks in Python that
are benchmarking uh our kernels from
Torch and I want to figure out how we're
going to uh have these benchmarks also
work on the raw CUDA kernels
without Torch in the mix and then from
torch C++ I pretty much want to get us a
full microbench suite and this is a
project where I pretty much everything
is incredibly verifiable. I've already
done the structure of everything and
yeah I I want to go from there. So
let us see.
Okay. So this is our current micro
bench.
I I'm trying to remember if I had some
sort of thing.
I think I did have like some sort of
basic script from before.
I just want to go see if I had my uh my
script set up from before.
Uh actually that thing was bad anyways,
was it?
I think I can still use it to start.
try to approach it as TDD. Nope. What
did I say? I'm not taking any stupid
viewer advice today.
Uh, it's going to be similar in the
sense that there is verifiability, but
it's not going to be TDD.
Last time I took all I did was take
viewer advice. It was the most
depressing goddamn stream I've ever
done. I went out and I had four
margaritas after that. That was awful.
profile. It's this file that I didn't
commit.
viewership for first stream. Don't care.
Now I'm actually trying to do something
useful with it. I did the first stream
because people really wanted to see and
that'll give me enough for the article,
but I'm trying something different.
This is still the bad timeline AI wise.
I think it doesn't have to be.
Okay, cool. So, we have this. Yeah,
this now works. GPU performance
counters.
Uh, I don't know whether we need those
or not. Fine.
Just glad it was Marg and not Runescape.
[snorts]
Yeah, I uh I might have also downloaded
that. Yeah, I might have downloaded the
game again.
Uh yeah. [sighs] Yeah.
But let me tell you, I am actually very
optimistic about the direction of Puffer
and Tech. Um,
I think it's based mostly just there's
there is more signal than before, but
there's also just way more noise. So,
the ratio sucks, but like
I can pick it out.
You have a lot of hope in people. I
don't have a lot of hope in people.
Yeah, Percino. I have hope in the
potential of humanity.
That's what I have hope in.
So, right now I've given it so far like
no control over this. This is literally
just going to remove like delete this
and then paste in the other stuff. But
my hope is I'm going to be able to use
this to speed up the uh the dev loop for
benchmarking and to like
well without really giving it much
control.
In the meantime, we can start reading
this.
So,
yeah, this just gets like a vector.
Oops.
One.
It's a relatively well-known bug.
I mean, I'm not surprised when the devs
of this thing apparently write all their
code exclusively using it.
Torch headers
soft plus threshold
soft threshold check.
Okay.
Okay, that's an incredibly obnoxious
bug. Holy crap.
really like it's RMR RF. I'm in a uh I
am in a standalone container espec
that's just for this
That's fine then. So what we'll do is we
will do
I can pass the stream to the launch
function right
move all launch functions that use
No.
Yo, why is this do Why is it like
flashing like this?
Is there like not a way to fix this
Does it get converted somehow?
Cuz this is a this is a torch object. So
actually, how does this go here? Does
anybody know? Like because this should
be this should be a CUDA object. This at
this is torch right.
So what we want to do is like stream.and
or something and then pass it as an arg.
It's the terminal emulator.
This is default to buntu like whatever
the default buntu term is.
launch.
Uhhuh.
Do a vibe code. No, this is not a vibe
coding stream.
I did the vibe coding stream last time
and it was the most depressing [ __ ]
imaginable.
What's the difference now?
I mean before you saw I was just like
programming in English. This is the
opposite, right? I'm actually like I'm
doing most of the code here. I'm going
through line by line and fixing stuff.
I'm basically using this to automate
like syntax doc lookups. This is a much
lower level of [ __ ] I resume this.
Is there a resume or did I just hit
escape by mistake?
you publish article. No, I'm waiting
until after I do this. Resume.
Yeah, flickering weird
dramatically different FBR. You will
see.
Okay, so
Z
equals Z. No.
Opus without brain damage. Opus with
brain damage was the last stream.
Zero thinking happened last time.
It's backward.
Yeah, this didn't change. Good.
So these are all just all the launch
functions.
So then this will make us have we will
then have a standalone uh we'll have
standalone kernels and launch functions
and that lets us write a test script
that doesn't depend on torch.
Oh, that's fine. Yeah, I can do that.
That's fine.
Matures gone up and for the develop
because basically I'm trying something
different today. I'm so last time it was
okay let just hand over control to opus
because I was listening to viewers and I
was like okay how should I use this
thing and basically everybody told me to
use this in the dumbest least
thinkingest way possible so now I'm
thinking well what if I'm doing my
normal work and I want precise control
over every line of output code uh like I
was working normally can I still can I
use this thing to help me in my normal
work without making me actively stupid.
So,
and if you're looking closely at what
I'm doing, this looks nothing like what
I was doing before at all.
Like, this is essentially the level that
I'm using this at now is essentially
just preventing me from screwing up. um
like function calls and screwing up like
typing and syntax bugs, right? While
also automating like fuzzy changes to uh
like very similar changes fuzzy to
several parts of the code at the same
time.
No, I'm not the architect. It's the
builder. That's too high level. That's
the thing.
Uh, and then this needs C10 food to
stream. Yes.
Like giving up the responsibility and
complaining.
Yeah, Liberty. But like I said, I said I
would do one stream listening to exactly
how people wanted me to use it. It was
dumb. So now we're trying it different.
This is not great. This is so the
project I'm working on right now. This
is a uh a real part of puffer 4. This is
uh it's a very verifiable task. I
already have uh code for this for the
sort of torch python layer of it. This
is a kernel benchmark. So we are writing
a kernel benchmark for all of our custom
kernels for cover 4.
Complete handover. The complete handover
is utterly stupid.
Completely and utterly stupid.
Like you should actually just be
embarrassed with yourself as a human
being at that point.
I I don't know. I don't even know what
to say. That was the most depressing. I
think that's probably the single most
depressing thing I've ever done in tech.
That was awful.
Okay. So, once we have this thing done,
we can probably come up with a pretty
good standalone um
like raw kernel level benchmark.
I still have to figure out how we're
going to do uh torch benchmark and
kernel benchmark at the same time.
I think I know though.
Are you not using any LSP fuzzy replace
with just reg x?
Yeah, this is a this is like a fuzzier
LSP. And no, this is more than a fuzzy
LSP. This is more than a fuzzy LSP.
Super Maven is a fuzzy LSP. This is
substantially more than a fuzzy LSP.
But the the key is I don't think I'm
really giving up any low-level control
doing this.
So, what did this do? This did static
Cath.
This is fine.
is good.
Uh, the LMS are better than expected.
The users are stupider than expected.
Yeah,
people are using these tools because No,
I'm saying that people are using these
tools uh because they're incapable of
thought.
Or not even that they're incapable of
thought. It's actually substantially
worse. Several of them are capable of
thought and do not want to think which
is in my view much worse.
So the idea of today is can we use these
tools in a way that I'm thinking exactly
the same amount if not more than I
normally am. I have precisely the same
amount of low-level control but I'm able
to get my work done more effectively.
And uh a key piece of this is I am
considering the code part of the final
product not just the result. Okay. So
both the result has to be at least as
good and the the quality of the code has
to be at least as good as well.
Do you prefer this over manually coding?
That's what I'm currently thinking,
Robin. That's what I'm currently
figuring out. I am going to be doing
some stuff manually for sure as well.
But like look at these dips. Do you see
how tiny these dips are?
It's using way too many freaking tokens
doing this [ __ ] but that's not a huge
deal.
Yeah. So, that's what I was doing before
with Super Maven after story. But, um,
you know, because we still have stuff
like making the same fuzzy change in
multiple places, it's a lot easier to
mess stuff up. What the hell did you do?
Okay. No, this is fine. Right. This is
expected.
Yeah, this is what I asked. This is
removing duplicate
yes, that's correct.
So, this is just all copy pasteed
duplicate code. So, this looks like a
big diff, but this is literally just
removing duplicate code. And then the
actual diff is right here.
corporate. You have you don't have any
deadlines in corporate, man. People do
zero work in corporate. That's [ __ ]
The vast majority of industry engineers,
even the well- paid ones, are doing
essentially nothing.
Everybody loves to pretend they're so
busy.
effort to save tokens. Yeah, but the
thing is I'm not sensitive. So, I'm not
super sensitive to the cost of this
stuff. And if if this improves my
productivity by a little bit or it makes
my job a little bit more enjoyable,
that's fine, right? The thing I didn't
like was uh this thing just making you
intellectually lazy and replacing your
conscious thought and your control over
the project. That sucks. All right. But
if I can use it to not do that and do
the opposite, then that's great.
So, actually, the only thing that you're
not going to hear me complain over is
the price of tokens.
Uh yeah, we can do microbench. I think
that's fine.
Lowle controls must. Yeah.
I don't even really want them to help me
design anything though.
I don't know why also I don't know why
it tries to um why it ingest the output
of every command by default fully
but whatever.
Okay.
Yeah, very context inefficient.
Actually, I won't complain about the
tokens, but the context inefficiency is
very stupid with that. Uh, that's fine.
I don't like how it spaces this [ __ ]
What the heck? One, two, three, four.
Why? Why would it be spaced like this?
before we add more of these, we want to
think about the allocations.
Yeah. So what we want is
Oops.
Okay. So, what we want is we want
something similar to this
where I have a test function that can
test with a bunch of shapes and stuff.
I don't really care too much about the
tokens to be fair though. It's not that
big of a deal. It's like mildly annoying
at most.
Using five bucks in 45 minutes is not
like that doesn't matter.
And that will get cheaper and faster as
well like very rapidly.
So what I'd like to figure out guys next
did you do any specific setup to make it
easier to use in this way?
No, I literally just stop. I just don't
outsource thinking to claude. That's it.
I well I guess having tight verifiable
loops on stuff like quick compile
commands stuff being pretty standalone
but like that's how I would normally dev
stuff anyways because that also makes it
easy for you to dev so I I really don't
like the idea of changing stuff to make
something easier for the LM and harder
for people but in this case it's
perfectly aligned.
So here's the question then right like I
have this profiling set up in uh Python
this is for the Python torch binds.
So uh the question will be
how do we do this in C++ because I think
ideally
yeah I think ideally
we don't even have this script uh at all
in Python because like measuring Python
overhead is just dumb. There's not
really a point to it. Like obviously
Python is just slow and stupid. Um, and
like if I were to take this loss for
instance and I convert this into C++,
uh, the code actually doesn't even get
any more complicated. So, yeah, the
Python is kind of just worthless. The
thing that I do need to figure out
though is how to do some sort of thing
like this where you just pass all the
arcs in.
I think what we're going to do,
we need something that allocates us
tensors
for
uh for all the args.
We need something that allocates us
tensors for all of the arguments
and then is going to be able to pass
them in.
Uh I can do it with one void star. I
don't know if there's anything better.
Random question. How are the degrees PhD
and doctor of edge
perceived?
I've never heard of denge. What?
It's just PhD
for whatever in the US.
Uh and then there's a lot of variance.
I definitely don't go like unfortunately
some people do just go off of
credentials. Uh I always just go by what
have you built.
Okay. [sighs]
So if we were
I think that the way that we designed
this right like obviously this all gets
allocated on
uh these all have to be allocated by raw
cuda.
You can bind these to torque handles.
Yeah, you can definitely bind these to
torque handles.
I think we can put it into a strruct and
then we'll just have the test function
take a void uh we'll just have the test
function take a void star.
Yeah, I think we can do it this way.
Yeah. The next thing will be
let's get these all cudamalic.
The correctness checks only need to run
at the torch
Yeah. I think what's going to look like
is this chunk of logic, right?
This is going to get into
We basically just need to have it so
that this loop here
get shared across kernel tests. Uh and
this is not just to avoid redundancy.
It's so that we don't screw up like
tests on a specific kernel so we know
they're all the same.
And also I don't like these just massive
test functions. We're gonna just do it
with um I think we're going to do it
with strus instead.
It'll be better.
And this is kind of the main thing that
I wanted to test today, guys, cuz like I
know pretty close to what the code
should look like uh to uh for this, but
it's still pretty fiddly and it would
still take me a fair bit of time to do
it manually and it would get kind of
boring. So I think that this will be
this will be substantially better.
Okay. So we have what are we doing?
We're removing the launch forward. Okay.
We have this.
Uh it's fine to put them all in one
strct. Yes.
We
do launch backwards.
Uh, this gets removed, right? Has to be
a three.
Wait, you can't do that in C style,
right? Like this is
turn
Okay. So, very small change.
I want this done C style
Well, I mean, come on. Think about what
I just asked it to do. Like,
I asked it to do a pretty small
manipulation where you're basically just
chucking these into a strct allocation,
right?
Okay, we get our calic.
We get this. We get this.
And we're happy, right?
Uh what I just did is a fair bit more
than that.
Like you're right that it's almost what
you could do with tools that are not
fuzzy, but it's not quite the same, man.
But you like you are pretty like you are
right that I'm using this in a way that
is like almost pretty close to uh a
standard IDE
Yeah. So, this is a test, right? Like
I'm assuming that these models are going
to get way faster.
I could always use the dumber model as
well. I haven't even tried that. I I
don't even know if there's a a huge
difference for something as simple as
this.
We don't need all these comments,
Claude.
Let's see what this looks like. Um, we
have this awful name, but whatever.
See, this was also from a model. See, I
would have never typed this myself. So,
we're not going to keep this garbage.
What even is this vector of float?
that I don't like here?
Posted device.
Yeah, that's a personal choice though.
20.
I don't know. Maybe in the future that
will determine who is worth a damn and
who isn't, right?
Like who actually just wanted to be
completely free from all conscious
Yeah. So this this like thinking time
very stupid for something this simple.
But
And the thing is like right now this is
arguably not even that much faster of a
keyboard at all. Um,
I think I'll have to fix it
a little bit.
a lot of university students and they
shouldn't be in university go to trade
school.
Like seriously.
Uh, does this have to be mount? Does
this have to be allocated?
Little annoying.
Not terrible.
Okay.
Uh, now we actually have a pretty decent
start on stuff, right?
Uh, let's try
Uh, I don't know if we can do with this
as a void star because it needs to know
the args, doesn't it?
Can't use voice ring convert the type.
Yeah, that's the only thing I'm not
positive about because I don't actually
um I try to avoid this when I can. I
think in this case you have to
Okay. So it's just when do you cast? Let
me see.
So in this one you this one takes a void
star.
Not a huge fan.
Uh
yeah, but like how do you do how do you
like what else do you do in C my guy?
There are very few situations where you
should do something like this. But when
you have a giant stack of uh methods
with the like they each take an arg and
like you need to apply the same thing to
them. This is what you do, right? Cuz
it's either this or a massive block of
um if else. And like it's not just one
big block of if else. It's probably like
before, in the middle, and after.
I think this is fine as well, especially
for standalone test.
Wait, aren't these like Wait, what? Now
I'm confused. Run log.
Wait, it just gave me two identical
things, didn't it?
That's why I'm confused. These are
actually
Cast function pointers at call sites.
Oh, I see.
I see.
This feels substantially better. I will
say
All right. What are we What are we doing
here? So, we're just getting rid of the
old one, right?
Cool.
Okay. So, this feels like outsourcing
the calculator. The other thing from the
other day feels like outsourcing your
whole brain. This is much better.
Uh, it's going to be a there's going to
be a pretty long article, I'm sure. I I
think it's that the models are good. The
users are stupid.
And the developers of these models are
also just kind of evil.
Is it faster though?
Well, Eigor, let I like this is this is
making my work at the very least
substantially less irritating and
obnoxious.
Uh, I think this is actually allowing me
to write slightly better code than
normal.
So I like this to me and I'm not losing
any control.
So I think that this is pretty good.
Co-pilot with a good UI.
Yeah, I'm not trying to outsource my
thinking.
Best time to be a student.
Um,
the thing is like if you ask these
things to just write better code, they
don't really know what that means
and these things absolutely do encourage
you to be intellectually lazy.
Okay. So this is create
free.
Yeah. So this thing is going to have to
get pulled out next.
oh, these run functions are redundant as
hell, right?
Yeah, these run functions are. So, we
can actually clean this up substantially
more.
Cool. Yeah, we can clean these up quite
substantially.
I'm use the restroom real quick. Um, and
then we're going to continue. I'm
actually This is way more enjoyable.
This is way way way better.
I'll be back
making a cup of tea as well.
And this is good.
This is very good.
Was it doing differently versus last
frame?
You can take a I mean watch and you'll
see
it looks nothing like what I was doing
before
just conditional sampling.
I don't think this is probability and
statistics. This is just like
interface and like do you want to
outsource your thinking or not?
Like the difference as well is here um
what I am doing now
right what I'm doing now I could not do
blackout drunk what I was doing last
stream I could do blackout drunk
this requires the like pretty much the
exact same amount of thought that I
would do normally but what this is going
to save me I hope is like this could
save me an hour or two a day of like
just screwing around with uh syntax
errors and like me copying [ __ ] around
wrong and like stuff like that and like
me forgetting bits of syntax because uh
you know the project has CUDA, C, C++
and Python. I miss stuff. I mix mix
stuff up every so often. And uh you know
like applying the same transformation to
five functions, messing it up here and
there like stuff like that.
Dude, after that last stream I like
directly went and got four margaritas.
This was like the most depressing [ __ ]
imaginable. That was awful.
what about these run functions? Are
these actually needed?
They're not, right?
Oh, yeah, they are because But actually,
they're not fully needed because
Yeah. So what we're going to do is
we're going to do like this replace
uh
object in main Alex
is etc.
Okay. There's one thing that we have to
figure out here, which is
I still have to pass a no AR kernel,
don't I?
I still have to pass a no AR kernel.
Okay.
Minor refactor on that. And then the
thing that I have to figure out is if
there's a way to get rid of this run
annoyance
Okay.
Yeah. We get rid of this. We go to print
out. That's fine.
no. Wait. Is this good?
Print log quotes and values
Okay, it's good.
Just need that.
Okay. So, I mean this can go up top,
right?
So for this kernel, we have a strct,
we've got a create, we've got a free
Is there any way to compact these three
into one cleanly or not really
It seems as bleak. It really doesn't
seem bleak.
Learn to code, man.
Here's the edge that you have. The vast
vast majority of entry-level people at
the moment are just being lazy.
So,
What's different with the approach? I
mean, look what I'm doing this time. I'm
not just outsourcing everything to the
model.
Change launch signatures to take a
strct.
Oh,
Yeah, not really. Cool.
Okay, we keep it this way then.
How big was open AI? Like 100ish.
It was really good when I was there. So
for all my criticism now, I always say
that OpenAI when I was there was the
best place I've ever been by a mile. It
made both Stanford and MIT look like a
bunch of idiots by comparison.
What have I missed? We are doing a uh
brain cells required opus stream. So I'm
basically trying to see if I can do my
normal work. Um but I can do this in a
way where this actually makes me more
effective
and does not really replace my thinking.
Okay, let's see what this is.
That's way too much code opus.
Uh, depends on how this experiment goes.
Tony.
I'm also probably going to try Sonnet or
whatever
because I wouldn't be surprised that
Sonnet does just as well at this. Like
the main problem with this right here is
this thinking time. This is really
annoying. This like breaks up my thought
process, but I think it's still worth
it.
Um, we will see.
hired any people.
Uh, I mean, I'm working with Spencer.
We're still technically doing things on
a contract basis, though equity is
available on contract basis as well. um
because it's easier, but we're basically
he's basically working on this, you
know, most of his time.
So, I don't have full-time positions.
Things are still officially done via
contracts and are structured for
contracts, but you can, you know, you
can do enough stuff that it basically
becomes the full uh the full week.
Is this the fastest one? I mean,
presumably these the models get way
faster very quickly.
So, the only problem is they keep like
they'll keep deprecating the old model.
So, you use the latest one even though
the older ones are going to be way
faster.
I too.
Is that model decent though or is it
going to just make a mess?
I mean, I'm doing pretty basic
refactoring.
You want to be able to run? Let me
think.
Yeah. So I would want to put it in
Eternals.
I mean obviously I can just do that
accept that and fix
What kinds of Sims do you build for
clients? There's one commerce and that's
open source that I'm still working on
offstream on new versions. There one
thing in defense. Uh another couple in
finance and we're looking at some game
stuff this coming year.
We've done a few other things as well.
Yeah. See, these guards are pretty
gross.
Okay, let me think. Is there a better
way we can structure these tests?
That's pretty funny. I'm using it pretty
much the opposite of him now.
Okay.
To the kernels
picking popular lip code base. Notice it
is headerheavy.
Yes,
it is in order to keep it simple.
Simplicity is way more valuable in RL
than elsewhere.
So, the single file thing is preference.
You don't have to put stuff in a single
file. Um, the reason that I like to put
stuff in a single file very often is
because you see the line count of your
project. And you know, if you're a good
programmer, you should have in your head
roughly the amount of code that you
think it should take to implement
something. So if you see that you have
twice the amount of code that you know
that it should take, you know you're
being dumb. Whereas, if you have it
spread up over a spread over a bunch of
files, it's way more easy uh easy to
like creep the complexity of the project
without realizing it.
No. 24. What the [ __ ] is that?
I turn two.
This is uh just default abundant term,
I'm pretty sure.
Yes.
Okay. This is good. This is what we
want, right?
Uh yeah, but it's like a header only
style thing. But
you don't need declar like I don't need
declarations like that. No, you don't
need to have the code twice.
Okay, I might try that in a bit. Then I
could try Oh,
I have ghost ghosty on this, don't I?
Ghost Tyt. I don't even think I put that
on this machine. I stopped using that.
actually here. I can I can add it
myself. That would be way better.
See, it's like encouraging you to be so
lazy.
You can't be lazy with it.
Okay. So, it's log co values.
Apply
Yeah. So most of these are become
internal then right.
Tough content creator. Cannot watch
every stream. Cannot keep up. [laughter]
Man, this is not even crazy hours for me
yet. This is like pretty chill hours.
We do get like some good 50 plus hour
stream weeks on the farm. I usually
don't work quite as many hours when I'm
in Florida just because it's
logistically way easier to work more
hours out on the farm, but
I do what I can.
Yeah, I'm in Florida for uh the winter.
I move around seasonally, so
You prefer the heat? No,
I actually I really don't like the heat.
Um, a few months out of the year in the
winter, it's not that hot
mostly.
Awesome setup. Yeah, that's good.
I also I spend a bit of time in
California as well and kind of move
around between three places.
I mean, the best setup is by far at the
farm, right? I got like my whole crazy
warehouse gym thing,
but there's um there's like a really
really good serious gym 10 minutes from
me here. So, that's pretty good. It's
not as nice as having all my own stuff,
but they have way more stuff, so that's
nice. Um, and that gym is kind of fun
because, you know, if I go to just like
your typical gym, I'm in pretty good
shape, you know, like I'm at least I'm
in pretty damn good shape. If I go
there, I'm like weak, man. That like
there are guys there squatting 500,
deadlifting 600. Hell, there are women
in there deadlifting four plates.
It's crazy. Crazy gym. So, it's kind of
fun.
I did sub seven minute pace though on
the uh the treadmill yesterday for a 5k.
So I was pretty happy with that. That's
a PR.
That's what like 22 minutes just under
22 minutes something like that.
Yeah, I finally got myself some PT setup
on my shoulder finally. It's my shoulder
just has not worked properly since
before the summer when I heard it. I
figure out what the hell's wrong with it
finally.
Okay, this thing
is obnoxious.
Oh, actually no. What we can do is now I
know what we can do.
arm
like this, right?
Okay, there. That's way better. See, we
wrote the scaffolding of it. I think
this is reasonable. I don't like these
guards, but this is a decent start.
And we'll see how this looks.
Let's see what we got. Okay, gets rid of
this. Good. Use torch.
No, this isn't going to work nicely, is
it?
This definitely does require you to just
not get lazy though because,
you know, it's always so tempting just
clud figure it out, right? But you don't
want to do that.
What the [ __ ] is that, Flicker? Well,
you see, um, the devs of Plug Code, uh,
just vibe code everything. So, uh, the
actual application itself kind of sucks.
Fair.
Yes, this is what we wanted. We wanted
uh from blob. Yeah, this is what we
want.
this feels so much better than um
the ship from last week.
I still don't think I'd want to do this
with everything though, right? Like I
think that there are going to be like if
I'm writing a new sim, I think that
there are definitely going to be times
where I want to still pretty much just
be writing all my own code line by line.
Um,
this is nice because I'm kind of forced
to play with torch
and
uh and CUDA APIs at the same time.
So I am really like this is kind of the
ideal use case
huh
is that a Okay.
I actually can't think of why that would
be the case.
fine.
Yeah, I see. Okay. You'd have to call
you'd have to call new on each of these
tensors.
So, yeah, I think we'll that's fine.
Yeah. Yeah. I forgot. You can still do
it. I see.
Okay, let's look at what we have. So, we
have
we've got the torch version of the
strct.
We're sharing memory, which is what we
want, right?
Run forwards. Yeah, we got this.
Names are super long. We might have to
think about that. But then this is
exactly what we want as well. This is
get cuda stream.
Okay. Yes, we can keep this for now.
Let's see what we have.
We're going to definitely do something
for these uh prints.
That's pretty good.
Now this is not profiling our module
level stuff yet. This is just profiling
our kernels.
Lip torch. I need to know how to get
those. Yeah, that's fine.
It is good and fast. It's actually not
good and fast reds. Um,
it's actually really not. So, you need
to do quite a bit of leg work. Um,
the reason I'm using the C++ is you
actually need to go lower level than
just torch. You need pudographs and
custom kernels.
And uh at least if with a C++ API, I'm
close to the point where I am I need to
be in order to do that. If you just port
to live torch with big batches and
stuff, you actually don't see much of a
difference. You kind of need everything.
>> We set up a standalone compile, don't
we?
Okay, let's see what this looks like.
Build X.
Let's go check what this looks like
versus our other ones.
I think cuz you have to import it from
Python otherwise.
I think it does need to be built as an
extension.
Maybe that you can just include sys
path. I don't know.
Okay. Profiles kernels.
Let's run.
Why would it be missing that?
It's probably just a build flag, right?
It should be LC10 here.
Our path.
Okay, this is kind of a hack, but
no, this is still nice. I think this is
still nice.
What are we doing today? Uh, I'm trying
to use Opus actually productively
without giving up any control over my
code flow. And um,
it's going pretty well so far.
This is actually way way way better
No, this is um so this is now a kernel
benchmarking
uh a kernel benchmark for the custom
kernels we have in puffer. And I thought
that this would be a good project
because it's like very strongly
verifiable.
It's uh it would be dramatically
annoying for me to do myself because I
know pretty much exactly how I want
everything written, but this involves,
you know, the CUDA API, the torch C++
API, a bunch of setup and build crap,
right? Um so it's like very annoying and
it's a task where like I can retain
pretty much full control over everything
and just do it a lot faster and a lot
less painfully.
Okay. So what do we have here? Cannot
initialize
I This is basically because we're
hacking the build instead of uh dropping
a proper extension.
Try this
weird torch setup.
No, this is uh this is not an N. This is
like custom kernel work on Puffer 4.
I like this because the logic of what
I'm doing at the moment is fairly
simple. Um, the design to keep it not a
mess is non-trivial and I have to do it
myself, but then there's a lot of
annoying syntax
um, and a lot of annoying setup.
So, it's a pretty nice test case.
There we go.
Okay.
One day torch will be less. Honestly,
torch is just absolutely terrible
engineering.
Like there's so much stuff in torch
that's just crap. Um,
now
Opus is going well. I need to write a
full article on it
like the article. The thing is, it's not
going to be a it's good, use it, or a
it's bad, don't use it. It's going to be
if you use it this way, like it will
make your work moderately easier and
like let you spend less time dealing
with [ __ ] If you use it this way,
you're basically loizing yourself. So,
it's not quite as simple.
Um, there are definitely a ton of things
people were saying though about it that
are just straight wrong.
Like, oh, it takes skill to use.
[ __ ] No skill to use whatsoever.
None.
There's like no LLM usage skill. It's
just there's programming skill and
there's intellectual discipline. That's
it.
Okay. So with this kernel we have
Yeah. So the forward stream is not using
the correct calls here.
there.
So what this is doing here right so this
is now uh all the memory is being
allocated in raw CUDA it's being bound
to torch and now this is calling the
kernel with uh those data pointers but
what we actually need to do is then we
need to call the torch module so that we
can get the overhead from that
What you should not delicate is your
thinking. That's it.
Like if you go in with a large amount of
intellectual discipline, caring about
the code that you're outputting, not
just what it does. Um,
what else?
Oh, and uh a very heavy disdain for
abstraction,
which is just generally good
programming.
uh you'll probably be fine,
but like the interface of the interface
and the advertising around this is the
most aggressively anti-human thing I've
ever seen. It's awful. So
Yeah. So this is genuinely a little bit
tricky.
Yes. So this is
Yes. So you remove these, you add these
I think this is good. Let's let's double
check when I can see the full thing.
So it's it's a little weird because we
essentially we need to do separate
forward and backward profiles.
Let me look at this. So we have
yeah this one is fine.
intellectual discipline. So, uh,
basically this model, the way that this
UI is set up and the way that they have
positioned Claude, it is designed to
make you lazy and to make you outsource
your thinking. This is terrible. Um,
this is the intellectual equivalent of
jumping out the nearest window. Don't do
that.
What you should be using this thing for
is or like removing the [ __ ] work
that you normally do that is associated
with like figuring out how this stupid
function interacts with this stupid
function because it's not documented and
like writing little tests to figure it
out and uh refactoring this massively
bloated syntax to this other thing.
Stuff like that. the stuff that's really
not thinking um but actually interrupts
your train of thought quite a lot while
you're trying to actually do everything
else.
That's what I'm like that's what I'm
sort of moving towards opinion-wise.
I don't think you need it for
everything. I think uh for instance, the
value of this goes down dramatically. If
you're interacting with exclusively
well-designed libraries that are nice
and succinct, then the value of this
goes down dramatically.
Um, for stuff like this, it's pretty
good. The code that I'm getting out of
this, uh, is the same quality as the
code that I would write normally because
I am actually like exercising control at
that level, right? If I just told it to
solve the task or something, then it
wouldn't be able to do that.
Whatever. That's one line.
It's kind of silly that just like, oh
yeah, that's going to take me 2 minutes
to do that. Um, that was kind of dumb,
would one generally not use
writing and I have a model. What
you can still write your own code. I've
actually several times on this stream
I've written basically the full logic of
what I wanted and uh I essentially just
had it fill in some syntax because so
this project specifically right think of
all the things I have I've got I've got
CUDA kernels I have uh CUDA stream API I
have torch CUDA stream API I have torch
uh what libtor C++ API I have Python
binds I have a lot of crap going on it's
a lot of syntax to keep straight in my
head, right? That's mostly what I'm
using it for, which is why I picked this
project. I thought that this would be
like a really good test case. You know,
there's going to be other stuff I do
where it helps. Not at all, and I won't
bother with it.
Okay,
this is good.
This is good.
Oops.
Uh, I don't know why it entered there.
Let me go see if I can figure it out
myself as well.
We're going to test if that's actually
the correct thing.
if you don't mind. How's your take
evolve since last stream? Um, so the way
that I was using Opus last frame,
because I said I would listen to exactly
what all of you said, uh, was completely
stupid. Like, do not do that. That is
awful. Um,
I'm using it now with way, way, way more
control. I have pretty much the exact
same amount of control I have as if I
would be writing my code manually.
I am mostly using it to avoid getting
stuck messing with uh syntax across a
ton of different libraries and languages
as well as to fix like setup and
building jank. Um I am still I'm not
outsourcing any of the control over
design of control flow. Um
so this is like way more using it as a
tool rather than actually just replacing
all conscious thought with it.
This is actually quite nice.
Last stream was the most depressing [ __ ]
ever.
double check this is actually doing
something.
Uh I have not started writing the
article. I will write the article
though.
At the moment, we're doing another
project with this. We're doing a uh this
is a kernel profiler. So, we're writing
good profiling code for all of Puffer
4's custom kernels,
which is quite important.
I figured that this would be a fun
project to do with this.
Let me use the restroom real quick. Get
another mug of tea and then we will
figure this out. And once we have this
done, we'll clean up the design and then
we'll be able to very very quickly do
this for all of our kernels and we will
have a really nice kernel benchmark
suite. And uh I mean this is one of the
key things that we need for
understanding how we get puffer to 10
mill steps per second. So good project.
I'll be right back.
Okay,
I'm having a good time with this.
This is uh
way way way way better experiment.
Way better experiment.
It's so funny to me that you have uh we
had like 200 people watching the code no
think stream [laughter]
and then you get like 20 some odd
watching actual good dev with effective
use of tools that don't rot your brain.
You guys see the issue here? So, I
literally commented out this backward
pass.
I don't think this is correct.
Let's go look. So, you call
autograd.backward. backward.
in the MMO crossover. Yeah,
I uh you know the MMO crossover that got
me good. I did freaking reinstall
Runescape again, [laughter]
but hey, I uh
this is actually going to get me back
some time
this way.
Honestly, like the thing is we're very
close with puffer to the point where I
think we can just if I were to just have
an environment for each pretty much any
individual boss, I think we almost to
the point where we can just one-shot it
with RL.
I mean like oneshot learning, right?
like you run one and to be clear that
means you run one automatic hyperparam
sweep with the default architecture and
it just solves.
I'm pretty sure that we're just about to
that point with buffer. Um
and obviously like a ton a ton of my
research was MMO inspired. There's so
many good things in there for RL and AI
in general.
Oh yeah.
Let me make sure I did this correct. You
guys are good marketing.
Yeah, exactly.
Jabrim,
that's fun. It I didn't actually mention
my own stuff on RS. Um I checked
actually.
So apparently I have about a 4.5 build
bank these days.
I don't quite have all the gear, but I
have most of it. So yeah, I actually can
start testing out a bunch of the new
bosses and maybe I'll get some ideas for
more RLMs. This is definitely research.
Yeah.
Time to raid. The problem with the raids
is like that's when you get into like
just really long sessions unless you're
doing solos.
I actually saw that um Chambers is back
to being worth doing and that's like my
favorite I think that's my favorite
piece of content in just about any game
ever and that's like that's why I did
the M fight of CRL environment.
I would like to finish that environment
though I don't know if I'm going to like
finish it with it might be worth it for
me to just go try to manually refactor
that code to see how bad it actually is.
We'll say
few gems. I mean, in general, I really
like the idea of like so MMO fights are
an amazing way to showcase how stupidly
good RL is mechanically, right? because
it's just like the devs making
mechanically harder and harder fights
and RL is stupid good at that type of a
thing. It's actually like doing a quest
would be way harder for RL, right?
So, it's a kind of a nice way to
showcase the strengths of the method um
to get something cool and then also as a
test, right? Like these Ms are also test
of the methods.
What advice did you get? I mean, people
just straight up don't want to think.
It's nuts.
Like, they basically just want to tell
the thing to solve everything and then
fix the bugs, fix the bugs, fix the
bugs, describe feature in English.
Don't outsource your brain. That's
awful.
Showing a little bit of field research
going to the boss.
That'd be fun.
Horizon length. Well, uh, Quest also
gives you English descriptions of stuff,
but like yes, horizon length. The way to
think about it is you're actually sort
of being told what to do. Um, because
you understand the visuals, right? Just
naturally. So, you understand, oh, if I
cut this tree, I get experience in this
thing. and then you can go read oh
requirement for this thing is this level
and you have a lot of just understanding
out of the box um but RL agents don't
bring that knowledge to the environment
right so it's very it's not very
self-contained
uh and the fights aren't self-contained
either but the thing is they are
actually brute forcible by trial and
error plus good learning from that
I could go into more detail potentially
but like that's that's the gist of it I
suppose
bot animation. Cancel a spell.
Yeah,
open AI5 is way more impressive. Way,
way, way more impressive. Yeah,
that's the best result in the field.
And that team was so good.
I don't know if that's the correct
thing.
And lasting impact on pro. Yeah.
I mean, it's kind of tough to show you
how hard like how ridiculously good RL
is mechanically at stuff. Um, this is
why we are going to ultimately want some
ends that are reminiscent of real games.
Like, I don't know. Actually having a
fullon fight would be really cool.
I don't want it to be some vibe crap
though. I wanted like actually make sure
it's good and correct.
zero the gradients before each backward
fall.
I don't think that's going to help, but
we will try this.
without this is going way better.
Hide your stats. I'm not going to put it
in the actual game, dude.
I don't want to I don't want to bot
their game.
If anything, I'd way rather like I'd way
rather help them use it for bot
detection somehow.
Yeah, that'd be awesome. I'd be super
down for that. I mean, RS is my most
played game and it's I mean, my PhD was
directly inspired by it. That'd be
sweet.
Ash is always
Yeah.
Well, I'd have to actually finish the
ends
and maybe get my master's home back. Be
a respectable player.
almost three.
I was so annoyed when I couldn't
freaking equip that thing yesterday.
run with the colonel uncommented.
Really?
A RPG style like I imagined.
Fun. Rel Celeste. Oh, very cool.
Like binding the game or re-implementing
the game. The big problem with RL on
real games is always just that the uh
they're just too slow.
It's like almost always easier to just
build a um fast sim.
So, the annoying thing with RL right now
is like
I've gotten puffer to a point where
Puffer actually works. Like you give it
a fast sim, it actually just works. Uh
the quality of methods and lit for stuff
in the lower sample regime is just way
worse. Like there are a bunch of methods
that claim that they work with very few
samples. Uh they're very slow and
they're also very fiddly and like the
quality of the experiments dramatically
overstates how good they are.
two days of training. Yeah, that's the
thing. Like I can guarantee you clearing
those early rooms, you'd have it
training in two minutes with Puffer.
Th00x less step than what you have.
Yeah,
that's uh I mean this is the whole thing
I did with puffer, right, man? Is I made
RL a 1000x faster.
So you're basically stuck with
pre-puffer levels of PF. I mean there
are a couple nice things with Puffer,
right? We do have some algorithmic
improvements and actually we are
expecting to have some sample efficiency
improvements as well uh in puffer 4 but
like nowhere near a 1000x
Let's see if we can find anything from
this profile.
I wouldn't be surprised if this is just
weird um
some like weirdness with how we set up
the profile.
When you return the save tensors, it's
copying them.
When you return the save tensors,
separate output tensors.
Oh, ironically, try this.
That'd be really funny.
No, not every waking moment, but it is
the major focus. It's more than just the
job, you know.
I think about it quite a lot.
I mean, I work out like pretty hard.
It's pretty hard to think about other
stuff in the process of doing that. I
get good sleep. I get food.
I mean, I the hours aren't even super
crazy in my view right now. Like, I have
blocks of work where I do crazy hours.
I'm not doing it constantly all year.
Pretty simple to use.
Yeah, I'm trying to make it even
simpler. It's tough. Ah, perfect.
I literally did this in order to try to
make it like more. Okay, whatever. Porch
is weird sometimes.
Let's try with the kernel enabled.
even simpler. Yeah.
I mean it's a balancing act in some
ways.
Respect to the discipline.
Yeah. I just did like um yesterday was
my first I guess it's on treadmill so I
don't know if you really count it but
it's my first sub seven minute pace 5K.
It's actually
faster than my best high school time.
And when I was in high school, I was um
like 35 40 pounds lighter.
So, I've been trying to beat that like
um that old time for a long while. I
don't know if I could do it on road. I
think I could do it on flat road if it's
cold out. I probably could.
And the strength work is good, too. I've
got about a uh 405 deadlift these days
and a two plate bench for five.
I just started squatting again. I had
been uh doing that for like a year. Um
that's going to take me a little bit of
time to get uh some weight back on,
but making progress. And then I got to
get my shoulder fixed. I'm going to PT
on Friday because I got this old injury
and I want to see if I can get to be
overhead pressing again. That was one of
my favorite lifts.
Okay, look at that. Now we have this is
on par. You see on par.
Get rid of contiguous.
sports. Yeah,
the gym I go to is like a really serious
gym and they have some good people.
I don't know actually what you would
call it, but
I don't know. We'll see.
If I can just get this thing back
working without needing some surgery,
that would be awesome.
I had a pretty decent overhead. I think
it was like 165 or whatever.
And I was trying to I was training for
like much heavier. I have all sorts of
really awesome shoulder training
equipment in the uh the gym in Maryland.
I'm not going to be doing dumbbell
presses again with shoulder press.
That's how I heard it. Screw that.
Honestly, the thing that feels on it is
um probably like log press is my
favorite. I know the neutral grip that
has with that.
All right, so this is now good. So the
thing I need to understand is what the
hell this is doing
cuz Let me just double check. I'm pretty
sure if I do this, it's now slow again.
All right.
Very weird operation. I'm going to make
a commit on this actually after this.
Okay, this is what does.
All right, that's fine.
Let me just go set all this up and uh I
will have this. I like this way you're
using more. Yeah, this is way better. I
mean, honestly, the other stream I did
just felt awful. That was just the worst
thing ever.
Oops. Clear this first and we're good.
All right.
So,
let's take a look at the design of this.
We have a 200 line profile.
Uh this is going to get the forward and
backward pass for one kernel
and it's also going to get the torch
versions with the torch wrappers.
Let's go look around for redundancy and
other stuff. Yeah,
my sip of tea first.
Okay,
we got our warm-up iters. We got our
timing itters.
We can't be lately. We got to actually
read through and make sure I didn't make
any mistakes.
We do device synchronous knives for the
warm-up.
But then we do
is this
not going to cue them in
parallel?
Okay, so they're on the same stream.
Cool.
Interesting. That is good then
is very good.
Okay,
let's take a look at this. So we have
just a simple strct
per kernel.
I don't really like these run functions.
I don't think there's a clean way around
this though.
And then the torch one is basically the
same thing. But we need the tensor
wrapper.
You need new because these are tensors.
Fine.
Uh you don't allocate any memory. You
just use this from blob thing.
Run forward once to set up the outputs
for backwards.
You don't need this uh this comment.
It's very obvious.
And I think the honestly the only thing
that's a bit jank is the uh printing at
the end.
Yeah, we'll just pull out the profiling
prints.
I'm going to move it a little bit, but
other than that, it's fine.
Okay. So, now we've got this.
That's cool.
And let's see what our profile looks
like.
And ideally, h we could do something a
little better with this maybe, but
So, we've pretty much gotten we've
gotten everything that we need for this.
It's not this one.
pretty much have everything.
This is going to be a larger diff. Um,
but this is basically like template copy
paste now. So, we did a bunch of work to
get this about as compact as we possibly
can.
We're still going to read through it
though very carefully. So,
it's your arc tensor.
The names we're going to have to
refactor at some point. That'll be easy,
though. Uh, okay. So we get
some mallets.
wall launch. And then here's your
mini group one.
Okay, I need to add this.
And uh then it's also going to need the
profile,
right? Which is right here.
Little simpler.
Okay.
Now we have extra 100 lines there.
So I'm going to re I'm going to re uh
rearrange a little bit.
I like pretty much everything except
where it put this.
You always group all the code for this
one thing together. You never group like
all the function of one type and then
all the functions of another type.
This is much much better. Now I think I
messed up.
Did I mess up this end if?
I think I messed up the end a little
bit. Let's go look.
Okay, this just has an internal one.
If
uh it's because it wants to put
everything in uh one
it wants to put everything in one torch
function, I say.
So, we're going to have to fix that a
little bit.
It's funny that it wants to do that.
and then we'll test the min gate
and uh we have I think two or three more
to port.
Uh, we do have to read all of this.
I'm just like looking to see if it broke
anything in the process. I don't think
so.
It added some silly comments.
It's the same same spacing. Didn't add
any dumb other comments. This is good.
This is actually quite good.
Okay, you don't need to have main here,
my guy.
Um,
I actually I absolutely hate how it has
this like indicator that's like vibing,
clawing, spelunking, and then All their
ads are like don't think.
It could so easily give us a little bit
like a one line of what it's actually
looking at
month since he didn't make change
through flawed code.
He didn't make a change through code.
Isn't this the UV guy?
What are we doing today? Colonel
benchmark.
Nice.
Now we have 303 lines for two kernels
and the rest of these are like basically
automated.
But it's very important that we have
this structured the way that we have
this set up and we have everything
shared the way it is. Um because your
profiling code has to be correct, right?
Like the worst thing ever is when you
have wrong profiling code.
Very good.
Using cloud code without brain damage.
Uh I'm using it with much much more
precise control over everything.
There's no vibing here. This is just
like
pretty much the whole setup of all this,
every single every single bit of this
was done precisely. I wrote um I'm
mostly using this to fill in syntax,
frankly. And then also to do like these
fuzzy sort of copies and this fuzzy
porting.
Like here we just spent what two plus
hours getting no like three hours I
think getting this done for the first
kernel and being very precise over the
structure of this. And now as a result
we can probably have it just port the
next kernels um in the exact same
format. But if I'd let it come up with
the structure of this test it would have
been a mess.
Yeah, I definitely did more work, Robin,
than if I weren't using it. Absolutely.
But the thing is, like if I were doing
this the way I were doing it yesterday
uh the other time, I would have gotten
negative work done,
right? If I just turned my brain off and
tried to do this, like the product of
this would be worse than not having
anything.
It's way better.
Yeah. I basically so I said that I would
do a stream, right, where I just used
the LMS the exact way that chat says
because everyone's saying, "Oh, you
know, the models are so good." And of
course, I mean, everybody recommends the
most brain damage possible way to use
the models and oh, there's a skill to
using. It's it's all [ __ ] Like,
the only skill involved here is actual
programming skill.
has nothing to do with what I'm
prompting or [ __ ] right? It's just
like me deciding on um like me coming up
with the structure of the tests
and you can look back through the bot
and see how much I did manually.
It's actually I really like this now
because this helps me spend less time on
the worst part of my job which is
essentially just here this thing right
now I have um CUDA syntax I have C++
syntax from lib torch I have lib torches
shenanigans I have mismatch between CUDA
streams from torch and CUDA streams from
uh I mean raw CUDA obviously C10 I've
got Python binds to deal with I've got
um like memory bindings from CUDA into
torch. There's a ton of stuff that all
has weird and very poorly documented
syntax. So, this essentially prevented
me from having to spend hours
bullshitting with that. And I mostly
spent my time today figuring out how to
get clean tests that will work across
both Torch uh and raw CUDA into one file
that are fast and are minimal and uh
will allow me to add several more
kernels in without making a total mess.
And this code is like this is exactly
the code that I would write myself as
well.
So way better,
right? We don't need this RMS kernel
because this thing doesn't even work
anyways.
Uh log co
I believe it is the
but that one does that even have a
launch
Yeah, I definitely think that if I just
like said write a kernel test for this
thing which lives here using this thing
that lives here, it would have given me
something that I would just not be happy
including in my codebase.
Um but because right because we spent
two to three hours
coming up with a nice way to do this and
I basically what I did here is I ported
the structure from my Python kernel test
and I had to figure out a few things
that were language specific cuz C++
um and then we tested everything. We
cleaned everything up and now when this
ports it'll port it exactly the same,
right? It copies the style perfectly.
So, this is much better.
I don't love the DT type mismatch here,
but I think this is okay.
Okay,
freeze launches
and this gives us
one liner.
here's the forward and torch.
the forward and uh backward and torch.
Here's our profile. This is identical
our torch profile. And here's our
current profile. And this is good.
What's different?
Um, so today I'm thinking of as much as
if I were programming normally
like because this entire
this is actually if you're just joining
now now this looks like oh look he's
still getting huge swaths of code from
claw but the difference is right I spent
this is uh essentially this is applying
a template right I needed to have a
kernel level profile that works for raw
CUDA as well as for torch in the same
file. And we spent three hours on the
first kernel.
Uh making like a coming up with a good
way to do that profiling operation that
is correct and succinct and will be
compatible with both and not mess up
anything. We fixed a few things with the
kernels to enable us to do that. And now
uh I'm basically just having it port the
other kernels over matching the style
like this exact template, right?
And then throughout I was using it to
cover syntax gaps uh to run some of the
existing tests a few other things but I
didn't actually have it design any of
this right
like at the function level I am still
implementing this I still came up with
okay we're going to do memory allocation
in CUDA and then we're going to bind
that those pointers are going to go to
torch we're going to allocate uh we're
going to fill buffers this way so
basically every single part of this is
my divine.
There's really not more than a line or
two anywhere that I can like do myself.
Yes, this is what we just reviewed.
Let me add
Now, what do we have now? We've got our
same 424 lines.
I think that there are going to be
certain situations where uh this is good
and certain situations where this is not
super helpful, right?
The thing that I like about this at the
moment is like
I can definitely see this encouraging
you to be lazier about the number of
interfaces and things that you have to
deal with because it makes it easier.
Um,
like for instance, Opus would have less
value here if I weren't dealing with so
many different annoying
language syntaxes and uh divergent APIs
and things like that. But
in this case, it's not like if I don't
use Opus, I'd work hard to find a way
around it. There just isn't a way around
it. It's just I need to have torch and
there's CUDA and there's C and there's
C++ and there Python binds like
this is already basically minimized
complexity.
So I think this is chill.
Cool. And now we have a nice fast test.
Interesting that this is such it's a
weird difference. It's a very quick
task. So it's a very very quick task. So
probably we need to apply some more its
no biggie.
Next one to port
Perfect. How did I join the chat? It's
on X, Twitch, and YouTube.
Be right back. Let me use the restroom
and we will check on this
Scan arc. Here's our tensor or our
strruct.
Okay. It takes all the arcs explicitly.
So that's fine.
Could malic
That's kind of funny.
It's actually nice that it did this.
I think we'll keep this. This is nice.
I'll double check this numerically,
but this is nice.
This thing still doesn't have numeric
checks to be fair.
We should probably have them,
but since I forgot, we'll just continue
this. And I think it should be pretty
easy to add them anyways.
forward.
Good.
let's copy this exactly.
Exactly. And exactly. Perfect. So, this
is just a exact port. Same thing as
before.
Uh, there's only one more of these
kernels
I'd say that's probably the reason is
they are not really
Okay, we got our scan. This is 566 lines
now.
This will simply have to be a fairly
chunky test, right? There's no way
around that.
Okay, so the micro bench one, this
version is way shorter, right? 264
lines.
Way shorter.
The trade-off is that you're way more
dependent on Torch here, right?
Like here we're using torch for all the
tests and here we have standalone
standalone CUDA which is really nice.
I kind of want to wherever I can I kind
of want to make puffer a little less and
less dependent on forges. I can over
time
in case we ever actually get a good
low-level
library that we can just bind it to.
Okay. So, this one is massive.
Massive.
Okay. So, this stuff is fine. This looks
super verbose, but this is just because
it's a massive function. Okay.
Yeah. So, the only thing that's super
weird is this thing right here.
Okay, so we actually do have that.
That's fine. And then
yeah, it actually is just like that.
I do think this is the least important
fernel, though.
of the kernels.
Yeah, this is just janky how I have it
structured. So, I think in order to
change this test, we'll have to change
the kernel, which is not going to be
worth doing until we uh assess the speed
to see if this kernel is even really
worth having because this is also the
only one that's numerically janky. I
know. So, I'm going to just take this
change.
Um, but if we do keep the ter if we do
end up keeping this kernel, this test is
not going to look like this.
Okay, so now we have giant
that was like half of the um Oh, no,
wait. That was not all right. So 300
lines. It's fine. 800 line 800 line
test.
Okay. So you can see this kernel is like
tiny, right?
Well, I guess we don't have um Yeah, we
don't have the raw torch comparison, I
suppose, right?
We just have the kernels.
Yeah. So, there's still a number of
different things we need to add here to
these comparisons to know which are
important and which are not.
Uh, these are reporting billions of
elements per second though, which is a
little odd.
Let's go take a look at
Okay. The backward check is
off on this log cos.
I should probably just rebuild just to
be sure.
I did I remember I messed with this
kernel before.
So, our tests are massively different
here, right?
So, we have a nice test, but I'm
actually
Yeah, I would think there's no way that
these are at billions
32 by 1024 by 24. Let's go take a look
at these.
This here. Put this over here.
Batch sequence.
Batch sequence and actions. Right.
Yeah. So because PO loss takes a
so
and where's F scan
log Kim sum X is B T and H
use scan is
+ one
H
Okay, so
we still have crazy numbers.
Let's see if we're getting a weird
multiply a weird multiple in here
somewhere.
Like I think what's min gate? This
should be the easiest one to make.
Correct. Right.
Ah see so rxn is wrong.
Yeah this is uh the profiling the
profiling is just multiplying by 128 or
whatever.
Yeah, it'll match actually quite
closely.
Cool.
I still doing research at MIT. No, I
graduated uh I finished my PhD two years
ago roughly. I'm working on Puffer
full-time. Uh currently this is I'm
working on benchmarking our custom
kernels for the 40 release.
Does this workflow beat Super Maven? Uh
it depends. So, I wouldn't want to do
this with everything.
There are definitely going to be things
that's just going to be way better to
write fully fully myself.
Well, I still like Super Maven for like
um like dumb tab complete saves typing.
This is kind of one level above that. Um
the thing is I chose a really really
good task for this today. Okay, cuz this
is
here we have CUDA, C, Python,
uh, and C++
as well as the CUDAGraphs API. Uh, we've
got the torch cudigraphs API. We've got
timings to deal with. We've got like a
bunch of memory sharing between CUDA and
torch. Like there's just a bunch of API
jigs, right? And it's very strongly
verifiable.
And I already have a version that I
wrote myself in Python.
And uh it basically this needed three
hours worth of me sitting down and
figuring out how to write the profiler
for one kernel. And then this thing is
very quickly able to like use that as a
template to port the rest of the kernels
in a way that's perfectly verifiable.
So it's a it's a combination of this
being a way lighter way to use it that
really saves more typing uh than
thinking.
And
uh this also just being a very well
suited task.
What are your peers doing? I don't know.
Join companies.
actually this now we can actually plug
fix this thing, right?
buffer work is something like that that
task. I don't know.
Um I guess we'll find out, right?
I think that this can save me a
substantial amount of time provided that
the way I'm using it is not producing
like worse code or substantially
different code than if I were to write
it myself.
It's very slow at the moment. I think
the main thing I have is that it's quite
slow. Um, it's still faster than me
typing it for sure for most of the time.
small fixes.
All right.
Now, let's see if our profiles look more
reasonable
experience until now. Today has been
very good.
I mean, it's a night and day difference,
though. Like, the last stream was just
the most depressing [ __ ] imaginable. I
went directly from there to four
margaritas with dinner. Um, today is
quite chill. Like,
I'm having to actually think. I'm tired,
you know? I'm like, I'm thinking
probably about the same amount as I
would normally. I'm not dealing with the
same amount of [ __ ] I would deal
with normally, which is nice. I'm
definitely getting more done.
And uh the quality of the work I'm doing
is on par with my normal at the very
least. I don't know if I'd say at the
very least
I probably wouldn't build this profiler
like normally even though I know that I
should have a profiler like this because
the amount of time that it would take to
maintain it by hand would be such a pain
in the ass.
But this is that like this is one of
those cases where you do just kind of
need something that's going to just be a
bit longer and there's not much of a
good way around it.
I'd probably stick if I didn't have
this, I'd probably have to stick to my
torch profiler in Python and that's just
nowhere near as good.
So I actually rather like this.
Okay, so 2.28 Q8. Yeah, this is correct,
right?
But I'm kind of thinking about in the
meantime,
these numbers
don't match up yet.
MIT looking to do research, I would
recommend joining a research lab. Uh, go
talk to professors and when they don't
want to talk to you or they don't rep or
when they don't reply to your emails, go
talk to their grad students instead
Let's see what this profile looks like.
I think we're still off, but some of
them match.
Some of them match.
Good starting point for sure.
Been live for 4 and 1/2 hours.
native we get 2.29 29
billion
I'm trying to figure out why this would
be so far off.
I can totally just have Claude go look
for reporting discrepancies while I use
the rest room.
tax the timing iterations.
Oops.
Might help.
I'd be surprised if it's just the
warm-up iters.
Be weird.
We have other stuff that we need to
check though.
That does change a lot.
That actually changes a lot.
Let's see.
2.29.
Okay. Log coefficient values is still
very different.
Very different.
Log [ __ ] sum x
actually. This is uh this matches now,
right?
This is showing our kernel is worse.
This is weird. Oh yeah, because we don't
care about that opta. That's fine.
And now
scan. Still way off.
Numbers are still way off. Okay.
Um microsconds.
Okay. So, stuff still doesn't match, but
we'll figure it out. Now,
other than that, what else do we have to
do? So, we have to time.
We still have to test correctness.
And we also have the time versus the
native C++
Well, we need a couple outputs, don't
we?
Oh, you know one thing I do want to
check.
Do we ever have a substantial
difference?
Uh, we do actually. Right. So, I do
think it's useful to have this overhead
check.
Yeah, cuz stuff like this, look, you see
that there's actually potential
overhead.
Okay. Um,
this is where I have to be getting this
is where I have to be careful, right?
because I've been streaming for 4 hours
40 minutes and it's very easy to get
lazy here and tell Claude to just do too
much stuff.
This might mess up with the auto
compact. We'll see.
It just has to extract some functions.
We're going to take ops very slowly,
very carefully.
So I can't get lazy.
So
let's go make sure that these are
correct.
It's very important kernel
tensor tensor list
Okay. Okay. And then we have the much
longer
What parts of the puffer algorithm are
original?
So,
well, it's a few things. Um,
there's this prioritized replay thing
that we do for on Paul. Um, there's a
custom advantage function.
Uh, what the heck else?
The
Puffer 4 has a new architecture that's
not in Puffer 3. What else? We have an
article on it.
I remember.
Oh yeah. Uh use muon. That was the
result of our extensive experiments is
that this is dramatically worth it in
RL.
Yeah. Trajectory segment filtering uh
puffer advantage and then there's the
prioritized replay.
So a number of different things, some
details here.
It's not vrace. No, it's a strict
generalization of um J and V trace
together. V trace alone is absolutely
awful. Um J alone is almost the same as
ours, but ours is a bit more stable.
It's a strict generalization of these of
those two methods. It's actually very
close to retrace
um as it turns out but developed for
Long hole.
Actually, I'm happy with that because
it's not going to mess with um
that's totally fine then.
I think if I want to move these into
somewhere.
Do that in a bit.
Opus episode 2. Dramatically better,
Tim.
Dramatically better.
Oh, for latte and stuff.
If you're using it to write paragraphs,
well,
I think I'd actually excuse you for that
because the thing is papers are [ __ ]
anyways.
Every goddamn time in my PhD that I
would actually put the effort in to
write a paper I was proud of, it would
get rejected. My best cycle in my PhD
was when I wrote three papers in three
days in the dumbest way possible and
they all got accepted.
So, I'd say don't use it for writing,
but academic writing is [ __ ] anyway.
So,
fair play
Walls agent
4 by 10 by 10
Uh
yeah. So Tim, chuck that if you're using
a com, chuck that one hot into uh just a
linear encoder just to make sure that
you don't have dumb com shapes.
That would be my suggestion. That's a
sanity.
Hang on. Let me think of a clean way
that I want to integrate this test.
We need to wait. Do we need to do this?
We We do
We'll try that.
Linear.
Linear layer after embedding doesn't
make sense.
Linear. You mean just put linear? No,
just don't use a comp. Replace the comp
for it. What do you mean a linear layer
after embedding? Doesn't make sense.
It's not an embedding. It's a one hot
coding.
It's one hot flatten linear.
It's not an embedding layer. You would
never use an embedding layer here.
You can go try it yourself. You'll see
that an embedding layer is like
ludicrously slow.
It's still very slow
standard linear. Did you try standard
linear on
um
on the one hot representation though?
Why is it slow?
Well, what dimension are you going to
embed it to, man?
Because like
you have four. It's a one hot of four.
If you embed it to 32, now you have 10 x
10 by 32, which is big. Card line is
just default.
Default with LSTM. Yes.
I'd be surprised if you need more reward
shape. Are you training Tim? Have you
looked at like our maze environment like
which is a grid?
Like are you sampling differentized
levels reasonably and whatnot?
default P. No, Migrew is puffer 4.
There's no mining in puffer 3.
It's actually kind of funny because it's
not going to even be standard mining in
puffer 4. I came up with a major
improvement to it.
Yeah, take a look at grid. So, pretty
much we just we make a bunch of levels
of um of different sizes and we cycle
through those
random level. But is it random of
variable difficulty or is like all about
the same? Like you need some easy
levels.
That might not be smooth enough.
Like I might just go from easy to hard,
right? I would want variable size, but I
guess what you're doing is I you're
giving it like global obs or something.
In grid, what we do is we give it
localized observations.
So we can use variable size maps.
It's pretty good
is hard and sample. Yes, it's a
curriculum learning. We have some stuff
on that. It's kind of tricky. Um there's
a the thing is uh we could devote more
time to that, but there's something that
we're going to be doing in Puffer 5
anyways that will just be better than
any form of that you could possibly
imagine. So there's not a huge incentive
to do so.
Hey, there we go.
Boom. Look at that.
Look at that.
little globs just five. Yeah. 5x5. I
think we use 11 by 11. 5x5 would be
faster, but you don't want to make it
use its memory too much for everything,
right?
one box, one target, no walls. Wait, is
it not solving the super basic task,
Tim? It should definitely like it should
insta solve super basic task
like insta insta solve
like simple for simple environments.
tougher one shots then
diffusion model RL they're literally
doing evolutionary strategies
okay what do we got now I got to not get
lazy
None of solving that. Yeah, Tim. So,
Puffer's like simple ends. If Puffer
doesn't solve and you did some amount of
hyper pram tuning, if you like at least
ran a basic sweep, uh, your end is
wrong. Like, puffer is just like good.
Got to feed the puff.
Oh yeah, speaking of which, for anybody
who's new around here, please feed the
puffer. Puffer's preferred cuisine is
stars. We have 4.9,000 stars on GitHub.
The puffer would be very happy with
5,000 stars, so please go ahead and star
the puffer.
That would help. It's free.
What you're watching me develop will
become the fastest open source RL
library out there uh by a huge order of
um well not an order of magnitude but
close to it. We're going to target 10
million steps per second in this
release. So if you like doing RL on your
laptop at home without needing a massive
cluster and still being able to do cool
[ __ ] this is the place. This is why I'm
spending so much time on kernels.
JLDR, what is your setup? Hey, Jess. Um,
it's pretty much just like me actually
having control over everything and using
this to save me a lot a lot of typing
and uh not letting it make any design
decisions
and nitpicking everything.
Um, it looks very different from the
other day. This is producing like the
same code that I would write by hand now
because I'm forcing it to
So here's the thing with um different
acceler accelerator backends.
Everybody's being real stupid at the
moment with those.
For some reason, the conclusion has been
that in order to support different
accelerators, you need to write
everything in Python.
So, I'm not messing with that. Um, I'm
just going to write CUDA because this is
what I have. Like, TPUs don't have a
low-level interface that I'm aware of.
It's all jacks. Um I'm definitely not
doing like niche other random companies.
So eventually I hope that there will be
some CUDA like language that's about
that level uh that just compiles to
everything.
And the assumption that's baked into
that is that the different uh
accelerators will converge to a similar
architecture
which would make that possible.
if that makes sense to you.
Yeah, compiling Torch Python to Jack's
Python is blending a C++. Oh, cool. Um,
it's still a small company that just has
some chips, right? Like
Excellent. Very much recommended. Very
readable.
What's the code look like? Is this not
meant to be human readable? What is it?
I didn't know that there was actually is
there actually a human readable
language?
Wait, with like Razer the gaming
happening.
That's cool. I have a bajillion Razor
things. So, [laughter] the camera, the
mic, the headset, uh the laptop,
freaking keyboard, mouse.
I got all the Razor things.
I can't recommend their laptops,
unfortunately.
They are very, very nice, but they don't
actually work.
Okay. On one hand, this profile file it
like this profile is just massive. On
the other hand, uh this is not massive
because I've been lazy.
I think this is just genuinely the
amount of code that this takes. I don't
think if I thought about how to do this
shorter for a couple days, I could do
much better. In fact, I think I'd
probably make it shorter but more
complicated and ultimately worse.
So, I think that this is good.
Uh I will build it myself. Thank you
very much.
Questions from someone.
Stop around five to six. Yeah.
What's up with questions? Convert
because it's using my stuff as a
reference. C10.
Well, if people have questions like
this, just come ask, right? This is I'm
streaming, right?
I don't have to get off frame and then
answer questions.
I don't know if this matches our other
profiles, but at the very least, it's
self-consistent, right?
How big is this stupid file? Still under
a thousand.
Still under a thousand.
Get rid of this bot.
Okay. So, I have to think a little bit
about there's a couple there are a
couple consistency checks I need.
Um,
couple consistency checks,
threads, kernel shapes. Yeah,
I mean these are custom kernels though,
right?
So,
there's I think one more major feature
this thing needs and then we need to
make sure everything's consistent and
nice.
A lot of autotuning people use. Yeah.
Uh, so the problem with the autotuning
thing is like
it's not really a good way for me to do
it standalone as far as I'm aware.
It's kind of all wrapped into bigger
stuff.
I should But I Hey, now that I have this
benchmark, it'll be substantially
easier, right, for me to uh to play
with.
How much does each thread do?
What do you play around with threads?
Yeah, that those are just launch args,
dude.
I have custom fern, so obviously I have
to specify all that.
Let me use the restroom real quick. You
replace the GPU. It might not be.
Yeah, that is true. Um, these are very
light operations though. Like,
it's kind of a different regime than
normal. I could try it on different GPUs
to see, but like I definitely need to
have this script be better to make it
easier to do that.
Yeah, but like there's not that much
total work
is the thing.
These are very small small kernels,
right?
Like these are tens of microscond
kernels.
I'll be right back. I'm use the
restroom. I'm going to grab a drink. I'm
going to walk around a minute and then
we're going to figure out
I don't know if I add pseudograph
support to this thing yet or whether I
do um
or whether I go double check this versus
the other profiles. We'll see. But this
is going to end up being about a
thousand lines for these five kernels.
So, not terrible. We'll be right back.
and then we need to make sure
everything's correct.
Work in a bipit place and is wondering
about approximate SPS.
About as fast as you can run the thing.
Probably
Guess for a good SPS.
Simple millions.
You finish cutting? Yeah.
Um, but on my work days, I just don't
eat during the day. So,
oh, you know why I'm starving? I forgot
to make myself God damn it. That's why
I'm starving today. I normally make
myself like a ridiculously heavy protein
drink in the morning and I forgot to
make it today.
Okay.
The only other feature this thing needs
is cudigraphing.
We only need to cudraph the C++ one as
well.
See, this is where it's getting to the
time of the day where I'm really tired
and it's very tempting to let Claude do
too much. We're not going to do that.
Instead, I'm going to make a quick
commit.
We already have this nice little capture
graph function.
It might be tough to capture the
backward graph, right?
Eight grad hidden. We can use the same
same one I think. Create
That'll simplify so we don't end up with
a bajillion of these when we go to do
the graphs.
It'll actually make it quite easy.
Yeah. How much have we used on this uh
balance?
I'm a little bit confused what happened
to be honest because
It said that I'd used way more credits
and then I looked back and it's like
refunded me some.
So, I actually don't know how expensive
this thing is.
Whatever.
Yeah. Yeah. You can merge those
functions.
That's nice.
Well, I'm not using it that way, dude.
Have you seen the stream?
I don't know how long you've been here.
Not losing brain cells today.
just joined
watching 2x speed later. So um today I
spent like three hours designing the
profile interface. had already spent
many hours before that doing it in
Python but redesigning it in C++ to be
compatible with raw CUDA as well as
torch binds. Um I I used claude to help
with syntax on that and then basically
to apply that as a template to all the
functions I've been porting.
So this is mostly saving me a massive
amount of um typing and fixing minor
syntax bugs. It's not really doing
anything higher level. Uh, it's not even
making like any lower level decisions
that impact Perf at all.
So, this is like way way way more
control. It's producing. Another way of
looking at it is I'm producing the same
code with it that I'd be writing by
hand.
Okay, cool.
Uh, let's try.
So that's just merging together. I made
one very minor error. Not even an error.
I didn't realize I was doing one
redundant thing. So this will actually
save us some lines.
All right, let's make sure it does it
correctly, though.
And then the last the last thing I want
to have done today is I'd like to have
two photographs applied to this
The last stream that I did was the most
depressing [ __ ] imaginable.
This is completely different.
Yeah. So this is redundant.
Same pattern.
Yeah, the LLMs are better than expected.
Much better. Um, it's the usage pattern
was the thing that was just utter crap.
To be fair, I'm also the thing that I'm
doing right now is like I kind of picked
the best possible scenario for it as
well
cuz this is like unavoidable syntax hell
of three or four different languages and
a bunch of different libraries. Yes.
Let's try
make sure that this is here and then is
this
880 lines? I think we saved like 50ish.
So then I should be able to have about
100ish for uh about 1,000 lines for this
full test.
Right. This is the bad kernel that I
didn't bother with.
Everything else matches what we'd
expect. Right.
Yes.
Cool.
So now
last feature we need to add is CUDA
graph support.
But I'll tell you what, I sure as hell
don't have incentive to hire fresh grads
that were uh using Opus in the way that
I did last stream.
Like if that's what you're doing, you
genuinely should have gone to trade
school.
Like you'd be much happier and you would
actually have a job. Um
like you have to think. Like if you're
using a tool to replace your need to
think,
then you're just in the wrong line of
work.
OnePlus X for productivity. It's going
to be heavily heavily task product task
dependent. Man,
the thing is like it's hard to even give
that because I wouldn't have written
this test if I had to do it by hand,
right? I would have done something
slightly worse that I could have done
quicker in a day or two.
like there are going to be several
things for which it's going to be like
zero increase, right? It's just not
going to help at all. U and then there
are some things where it's going to be
like two or 3x,
maybe a little more. The thing that's
more important to me though than like a
raw productivity multiplier is that now
instead of using this to try to automate
thinking um this I'm using this to now
automate the most [ __ ] parts of work
which are dealing with tons of stupid
syntax from a ton of stupid libraries
and a ton of stupid languages
as well as like fuzzy application of the
same pattern to a ton of code.
are just by coding their homework now.
Yeah, if you're doing that, you
shouldn't be in university for CS.
Like just literally go like go learn to
weld. You will be happier.
Yeah, definitely a win. And this is a
very valuable test like what I'm writing
here. This is a very very important file
for Puffer 4. Uh because this is what
tells this is what is going to tell us
exactly how fast all of our kernels are
and how important each of them is.
So
I am getting tired though, so I can't do
this for much longer.
Um,
and I don't want to like screw up and
let focus do too much, right? So,
Oh, man. What? How the hell do we have
What was this? Where's blood? Yeah, I
have it here. It's the other one.
suggest you do multiple. No, I don't
need multiples.
Oh, hey Ryan. I've been catching streams
but one to four line. Chat GP for
standalone scripts. Do you think flip
code is useful for larger changes? Um,
it's definitely useful, but you don't
want to let it do too much.
I'm giving it very isolated changes and
very little authority over control flow,
design, or anything.
It's pretty much saving me typing and
saving me from screwing up uh syntax
with a whole bunch of different
libraries.
There are definitely things for which it
would not really be that helpful at all.
But then this thing that I've chosen to
do today is pretty much the best case
scenario for it.
Human reason it's useful.
That's just such a repugnant view to me,
dude. I don't know what the hell's wrong
with you.
Like actually go touch brass man.
His model should not be giving you
depression.
Have you found that takes less time to
describe the problem? No, I'm not doing
it that way, man. That's the thing. If
you I did a stream. So, I did one stream
that was just vibe coding crap. Exactly
the way the chat told me. It was the
most horrible, depressing, dehumanizing
[ __ ] I have ever done. It was awful. Do
not do that crap. All right. And now I'm
not do like I'm not doing that anymore.
Right. I'm basically I spent three hours
today setting up very carefully like
exactly how I wanted a profile to be
using it to fill in bits of syntax and
now I'm essentially using this as a
template and having it apply this
template to a bunch of different
kernels. So it's like the ideal case
where you have CUDA C++ Python and C as
well as torch lib CUDA and then the
graph APIs for both of those. So you got
a bunch of syntax crap around, right?
And you have a pretty regularly defined
pattern where I've already written all
of the logic out for all of this and
I've already compactifified it and made
sure that everything is nice and clean.
The average the average CS Brad should
have been worried way before this, man.
The average CS Brad wasn't doing
anything before these models came out
anyways.
probably would have had to reference a
bunch of dots. Yeah, the docs are like
bad.
Um,
here I can show you the type of thing,
man. Look like
So like if I just pulled it to write a
profiler, it wouldn't have structured it
like this at all. So I came up with
okay, we're going to have this strct
which is going to have raw data in here.
We're going to do all of our allocations
as raw CUDA Alex here. We're going to
set data like this. We're going to copy
it over. We're going to get rid of
buffers. So this whole structure, this
was the initial function that I did.
Okay. And then I was said, okay, so now
what we're going to do, yeah, we have
our freeze, whatever. We have our run
function wrappers that are going to
launch it. Uh it's going to take a
pointer to that strruct. This was my
design as well. And then in torch, we're
going to have a uh another strct that is
the same thing but has torch tensors.
This is what I came up with. And then
we're going to use the data pointers
from the CUDA allocations instead of
using torches allocations. This was mine
as well. It's going to still have a
struck pointer like this. uh we still
have the same run functions for torch
and then the profiler is going to use a
single profile function that takes this
kernel function which is just like a one
arg function like voidstar basically
this was my design as well uh and then
we're going to have under a macro guard
we're going to have the torch version
here which just does the exact same
thing like this was all my design right
and then I have five kernels that are
like this so like you can see there's
not really a shorter way to write this
code here. This is like a couple hundred
lines of code and I have five of these
kernels.
You see
that's a lot of code and it's like you
know me I will write shorter code if
they I can write shorter code. This is
one of the cases where like the simplest
solution is genuinely just quite long.
Now we're going to add cudigraphs
support. Did it do four or five of them?
Uh I used it I used it the whole way
through but it's the question is how did
I use it? Right. So
I already had I wrote this a while ago.
So I gave it this because I wrote this.
So I already have this test in uh in
Python. So then I came up with the
design of this for C++ right and bit by
bit I had to implement chunks of things
for one kernel and I edited stuff a
bunch and I redesigned stuff a bunch
until I got it nice and compact. Uh I
also gave it where is it? We have my
kernels. I had to re I had to change
some stuff here.
Um, yeah, I had to change some stuff
with the launches here to make this
work. I gave it reference to modules.
So, it pretty much has the exact thing
that it needs already uh in like
different languages and with slightly
different design. Um, I guess the the
ultimate thing to think about here is
just like I use this to write the same
code that I would have written faster.
This is not it writing different code
than I would have written.
I didn't say like go write a profiler. I
didn't say like, you know, here are some
guidelines for how to write a profile or
go do like right. I had pretty precise
control over the whole thing.
It keeps tabbing out of that. I
sometimes remember to tab it back in,
but that's just as good if like if it
just proposes something bad, I just
like, you know, correct it anyways.
Similar to how tried to use in the past.
Better interface, probably better model.
Yeah. Now, the one thing I will say is
uh the way that it's advertised and the
a lot of how it's like intended to be
like this is the totally wrong interface
for actually thinking, right? So, it
very actively pushes you towards not
thinking. Like, this [ __ ] should not
live in another terminal. Like this [ __ ]
should live in my editor and it should
be like it should probably be doing
stuff you know like as I'm typing here.
It does you don't need a different IDE
for it either. It's a very very bad form
factor essentially for uh for
maintaining independent thought. So you
do have to be quite disciplined about it
like you cannot just outsource your
thinking to this stupid thing. Um I'm
very happy with the result of this. Like
the difference is the thing that I did
on uh the other day I basically had no
ownership control or investment in like
the actual outcome only in the result of
it. Like I didn't have any investment in
the code itself only in the result. Here
it's writing the exact same code that I
would write normally.
No, I'm not telling it to I'm not
telling it to go propose a plan. I'm not
doing that anymore.
I don't need it to propose a plan for
the thing. I know how to do it, right?
You cannot turn your think your thinking
into a purely discriminative process.
That is labbotomizing yourself.
It produced and seemed pretty miserable.
Yeah. So,
it's rough. I would not like I also I
literally I went straight from that
stream to dinner and had four
margaritas. It actually took me several
hours to process and internalize that
actually I don't hate these models. I
hate the users
and the developers to be fair for like
making it in such a a form factor that
discourages thinking. But you can
actually use these in a way that
supports your own like that actually
supports you uh and allows you to have
full control and allows you to learn the
exact same amount that you would learn
if you were writing manually. Um, and it
will be faster on some tasks by a lot
and not by very much if at all on
others.
Oh, also people saying that there was
like some skill in using these are just
straight up delusional.
There is no there's like actually no
skill whatsoever involved in using these
tools. Um
the only thing that comes into account
is skill as a programmer and you take
that out of the equation if you just
vibe everything.
So
you have to maintain authorship and
control.
Yeah, I really don't actually like big
autocompletes while I'm typing.
I actually Ryan I actually wish I could
disable multi-line complete in a super
maven. I never want it to complete
multiple lines.
want it for filling out
dicks instructs.
Yeah. See, I'd rather I'd rather just
have it be single line tab for that. Um
because otherwise it tries to multi-line
tab too much stuff.
The thing, the difference, Ryan, is that
Super Maven is so fast that if you
wanted to fill out a strct and have it
be several lines, you just go tap tap
tap tap. It has like, you know, 100 ms
delay, which is why I want like super
fast models for autocomplete.
Um, definitely what you want,
right? So, this does need to be behind
this guard, which is annoying.
Yeah, I sort of forgot about that. Okay,
I don't like that. Let me think.
let me think how we uh how we do this
reasonably.
So the annoying thing here, right, is
like uh this looks almost identical,
but we need to conditionally include
torch
and it's it's a torch pudograph. It's
not a raw cudigraph as well.
Oh, and this bug is lovely as well that
it flickers.
Let me go double check this versus my
version
didn't support.
Yeah.
I mean, but the thing is like in this
case, you don't actually hate the tools.
You just hate the people.
good at math and physics. You know, I
started uh I started taking more math
heavy stuff in ML and it just wasn't
useful. So, I ended up doing a whole
bunch more I ended up spending most of
my time just doing research
research and engineering in general.
It was a way better fit with how I
approach problems.
Then if this works, um,
if this actually works, then I can get
it to like apply that as a template to
the rest of them very easily. It's the
same exact code. And then I pretty much
just have to go check this versus the
ref cuz I think there's some timing
issues, some discrepancies
and probably clean up some names.
Uh ML as a whole does need math
and it's not just stats. It's a hell of
a lot of linear algebra.
But that doesn't mean that everybody in
ML needs to be.
There are a heck of a lot of ways to
make progress and in my case
it was mostly.
Yeah, this is a way better bit was this
is definitely more productive.
Definitely. I picked the best possible
case for it. This is just the type of
thing that would be a pain in the ass to
do manually. Um,
but like ultimately I'm writing the same
code as if I forced myself to do this
manually.
Yes, graphs were huge.
Graphs were absolutely huge.
We're going to get We're going to get up
to 10, though.
They're like this. I need these kernels
to be um I need these kernel profiles
though before I can shave more.
and
synchronize.
I had this exact issue before.
We literally have the checklist. Don't
start separate teams streams before
tracing
and GPU buffers.
Make sure input and output don't change.
Restore original stream after tracing.
Yeah.
Uh, this synchronized was the one thing
I did see. So, we'll see if that fixes
it.
That was different.
Let me make sure we're using this the
right
Well, I mean there's definitely that,
but like also I think that this is I
mean this is the best
like other than LLMs, this is the best
candidate we have for um
like long-term progress in AI. There are
a ton of problems that you'll just never
solve with LLMs that you will solve with
RL. Um, it has direct applications in
scientific simulation,
in like tons of logistics. There just so
many different places where this stuff
is obviously useful if we can just make
it sane and stable and just nobody's
done it.
real world measure how much you think it
impacts other people. That is not what
real world impact is.
I am embedding question for comms. If I
have a scalar ob such as a flag for
being in check, I can split it out into
a linear layer. Yes, no need for
stacking a one hot pawn.
Yeah, you can spit it into a linear
layer if you just I mean it depends
where you attach it in the network
though, right? So, just make sure that
you're not attaching it too late if you
want the network to know about it ahead
of time.
Graphs are fully done. Can't recommend
enough. I mean, I'm going to profile it
to see what that's like wasting. I don't
think breakout's going to be a good M
though to test that. It's probably going
to only be noticeable in big action
spaces.
I use many params and fewer params do
trick. Ryan, the target for puffer 4 is
10 mil SPS. We're already at seven. We
are going to hit 10 for sure, but it
requires custom food to help.
Okay, now this is annoying because I
actually have no idea why this is
broken. Um,
When will I be satisfied? 10 mil sounds
good.
I mean, this is now this is a 900 some
odd line profile script from today. And
believe it or not, this is actually
quite compact. Like, it actually pretty
much has to be this long.
Like, or let's say if you were to make
it shorter, you would actually make it
substantially more complex than just the
stupid thing that's long
with maybe a couple small exceptions on
this one function.
Um,
let me see.
mutable
grad
I wonder if you can't trace a backward
independently.
So this is just going to be the backward
graph, right?
Maybe you can't graph. Um, can you graph
just a backward pass?
I wouldn't be surprised if there's
something sketchy with that.
Oh, yeah. Cuz we do torch empty and
[ __ ] right?
Okay. So, I'm trying to think what we do
with this. I don't I don't think that
there would be an easy way to do
Do we actually need to graph
the forward independently?
I mean, I can subtract the time for the
forward pass, but that's going to be
misleading, isn't it?
I'm trying to think what the best
solution is.
It's more than just the raw speed. It's
also the precise understanding of uh
where our compute is being spent.
Yeah. People say there's a limit to
hardware back when they were running RL
at 1,000 steps per second. I've made it
a thousand times faster and I'm still
going. like
speed matters.
The difference between RL working on
like uh a single big node and RL working
on your laptop is that if it works on
your laptop, then RL will never ever be
behind closed doors at companies. It'll
just be out there and like widely
distributed and being applied way way
way more uh on pretty much everything.
The theoretical limit is very very far
away from where we are now
and nobody even [ __ ] understands like
the how, where, and why of it because
nobody bothered to profile. So,
how be would we go about getting your
Opus set up? Stop like asking it to vibe
[ __ ] for you, right? Like watch the
stream from the start if you want. Like
this is I mean I've gotten
the 945 line profile out of this. It's
the same code that I would have written
without Opus with Opus.
um but substantially faster and with a
lot less bullshitting
and importantly learning the exact same
amount I would have learned if id
written it myself as well.
Repeat my current issue. So it seems
like you can't graph the backward pass
of a network alone uh because Torch has
like a bunch of weird intermediate
buffers. So, I'm trying to think what I
want to do about that because I know I
can graph the forward pass and the
backward pass together with an optim
step. I think I can graph the forward
pass and the backward pass together
without an optimum step. I'm not
positive. Um, but then like I don't know
if I want to subtract the time of the
forward pass or what I want to do. I'm
pretty much just trying to figure out
how I want to approach um profiling
graphs.
if you watch the stream though, you'll
see it looks completely different from
the uh the other day.
Insert an event in the middle. Does that
work? What would that do?
The issue I think is that you're not the
way the backward is set up. It doesn't
reuse the same buffers.
It is probably is it this mutable? It
could be this. But then you also like
you make empty tensors in backward as
well that don't get reused.
Let me let me just let's take this and
see if this works first because I
actually don't even know if you can do
forward backward graph without doing the
optim stuff.
You're membound but like we don't even
understand how membound you are.
I know I can get the graph forwards.
Let's see if this still breaks.
Yeah, if I wanted to do that, it would
be some It would probably be something
like this.
Uh, what's is it like 300 T flops or
something?
Uh, what's T? Is it E12?
Uh, Gika's N. Yeah. E12
divided by was it one
So this is in megs.
Yeah, I think it's like two billion
steps per second or something
theoretical. The thing is you're going
to be way memory bound. Uh you're not
going to get remotely close. So you
can't just do the flop math like that,
man. uh you actually have to have an
understanding of what piece of code is
taking what amount of time.
Okay. Yes, you can compute memory
bandwidth, but it's way more of a pain
in the ass to estimate peak um like peak
utilization.
Uh the theoretical bound is mostly
interesting if you're close to it.
And again it's very difficult as well to
know what is it what is a realistic
theoretical bound or not.
Um, members
See if this works.
We can potentially just uh graph the
forward pass if not.
I don't like that idea too too much, but
we can just graph the forward pass if
need be.
Okay. So,
and I have to go pretty soon because um
we got dinner to get to. But let's see
if I can figure this thing out. Or if
not, maybe we'll just get something
quick and stable.
just see if that does it. If not, we'll
just do uh we'll just graph the forward
pass for now.
Too many optimizations.
It doesn't interest me for now. It'll
interest me when I'm actually pretty
sure that I have puffer like close to
where we can get it
because then it might inform me of like
additional things.
Oh, I'm just stupid. [laughter]
I'm just stupid.
Yeah, that's not even what we're
graphing.
The only thing we're scaling is [ __ ]
given about not letting your hardware
waste all its flops
do the same amount of work with a bunch
of consumer GPUs. Hell yeah.
Tougher.
We do offer professional contracts
mostly for custom sim dev,
but hey,
I I also did add I added like a $200 a
month sub on uh Twitter for like basic
chat support as well for professional
things.
I've not really advertised that one yet,
but it's still there. I mean, but it is
there.
If not, just start the puff run and
continue enjoying. It is all free open
source.
Uh, this is fine. We're just going to
get the Ford pass graphs profile for now
and then we'll figure out the other
things another time.
Sim is the only thing we'd not be
changing. I see.
Well, we'll have a lot of fun stuff
available in Puffer 4.
Just open debates.
We've got just like we have basic entry.
I mean, if you want to have a thing, we
pretty much just added it as an entry
level thing. Um, but there's like a chat
support thing you can buy on X that I
set up.
I kind of did it because I was sick of
having a million Slack channels and also
having to set up like tiny little
contracts. So, it is there.
RL for derivatives.
It's even more boring. That's funny. All
And then right about here is where I'd
want to stop anyways because I'm
starting to feel myself getting lazy.
Single digit long, boring and
frustrating process.
Okay, I am starting to get lazy. So this
is uh pretty much the cap for today.
Work on OSRS neural ML.
I mean it sort of does. Buffer is
profitable.
Growth has been quite good especially
considering that I spend most of my time
on the research.
I think we're going to by the end of the
uh by the end of this year pretty much
like any individual like old school raid
boss that you put in like any boss uh
would just get one shot with RL.
I'm pretty sure that that's kind of the
level that we'll have including the
tougher ones.
Obviously you have you'd have to have a
fast custom sim. I'm kind of using that
to say like any medium complexity sim
that's implemented correctly, I think
we'll be able to just one shot.
It's going to take Puffer 5 for that
though. Puffer 4 will help. Um, but
we're going to like there are a couple
core algorithm advancements we're still
going to need for it that I have
planned.
Okay. Well, we got to check the timings.
I think that there are still some issues
with timings and we're going to have to
do a lot of checks.
Uh,
but this is solid progress.
This is solid solid progress.
will create the Nah, we tried that last
time. That was terrible.
Most likely I'll end up creating the uh
I'll end up creating some environments
using some of the time that Claude saves
me from dealing with torch [ __ ]
if that makes sense.
All right, this is now in Puffer 4.
Solid day. 950 lines of code plus some
modifications to other stuff. Um need to
fix some things. I'm not 100% sure these
profiles are fully correct yet, but the
structure is quite good. Um, I'm going
to have to do a bunch of checks, but
like once we have this, this will tell
us where we are leaking PF, exactly how
much, how useful our kernels are. Still
some stuff, but this is like super super
solid progress for today. I'm happy with
this. Um, for folks who are new around
here,
you can follow me on X.
I'm live here. I also post a lot of
stuff, including articles, and the
article about Opus will be right here
and nowhere else in a few days.
Uh, if you want to support my work for
absolutely free, feed this puffer a star
on GitHub. He likes stars. If you want
to get involved with development, all
our stuff is open source. Most of it is
not this hard. Most of it is like
low-level gamedev that actually turns
around and does help us advance RL
research. So, you can check that out
here. Other than that, X is there. Docs
are here. All open source. Thank you
all. Have a nice evening. I will be back
maybe tomorrow.
Definitely on